[Music]
djay will you marry me yes this wedding
it's one that I never thought would
happen I get to marry the love of my
life alongside my sister and my best
friend eternal wedding day doesn't just
marry me he's marrying my entire family
just want everything to go well well how
is Steve handling this I'm a nervous
wreck
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
why does it have to end people liked it
so much I'm not ready for it to be done
I want to bench more what are you guys
talking about hey Zuri I wanted a
husband and a family dan needed a wife
that could wait on him I would have been
treated better if I'd been a dog and
served my master I'm amazed it only took
one bullet to kill Dan Broderick I was
married for 16 years then he turns 40
and he's walking out with a 19 year old
on a sports car I've been robbed of my
children court order Dan had me
committed to a psych Court I'm not the
crazy one he is
[Music]
you want to destroy me
he's in control of everything what else
am I gonna do
[Music]
also call me Betty
don't freak out
[Music]
we have a problem I think we might have
a few problems
Oh stole my goodbyes when I said you're
free you're gonna make it out from under
this I try with open eyes but I couldn't
see he doesn't have any proof maybe
that's why he's here to get cheated
[Music]
you gotta figure this out from wanting a
[ __ ]
I thought this was over [ __ ]
[Music]
what if they're watching him now what if
they're watching all of us
[Music]
I look at you clay and I see a kid it
was paying very high price
and I don't yet know what for I suspect
it might be for secrets you keep at some
point isn't it like enough is enough
continue all this down with you
this is really falling apart
[Music]
I think you've been keeping secrets
are you ready to let those secrets out
so what's your story your insecurity
that's what I do
[Music]
where are the diamonds this morning one
of the informants photograph these
people meeting with the senior al-qaeda
operatives on South African soil a
weapons coming into Cape Town and he's
using blood donors to pay for it I won't
would they transporting found and what
does go stop to get to work
it's a call moves smoothly to get up
they have always been the targets I keep
my job no diamonds no money we will let
you away for life
wait what debt looks like they've been
tracking a ship that's how they're
bringing in the weapon tell me who hired
you I should have just q1 is targeting
our witnesses you think they're trying
to cover their tracks it's gotta be
something we can do no walk away there
are lives at stake here
[Music]
we had an expected
ready these are our new friends Wow
hello we're like emotional support dogs
except we're human you guys can stop
holding them now it's really comforting
though lots of eyes on you
breathe here's my employee I'm ready to
make this day my [ __ ]
I'm just nauseous and exhausted my boobs
got hurt
wait are you serious I already lost
scarlet and my apartment
I can't lose anything else these don't
feel like me I haven't dealt with it I
can't give you what you want
she's having a moment let me have my
moment I just feel like a bleep should
be used okay
the bolt type new episodes Thursday June
11th on freeform
[Music]
- Stephens the jewish-owned to try to
rob a private sector garages de Novo's
noctilum doing a big volumes going to
attractive
stereo sub reverse with the last we need
a new couch Hugo Chavez knowledge
another zip code
Papa's esto III chiefdom Chihuahua he
shows three of the new acknowledge you
similar systems like newly registered
initiatives mistaken
don't look
[Music]
just mercifully snow off something
mushroom
I mean as a yeah
because in my pain
there is interest after the blusher
[Music]
Wow I'm gonna be the best night the
kingdom has oh [ __ ] ten years of
training has led to this how am I
supposed to be at night for these people
this is a cesspool nothing separates the
men from the boys like combat why do we
have to strip for this like I said men
from the boys now line up according to
bulge Patrick we can put every prisoner
to death
exactly an execution is a sometimes
trick like ice cream and BUTT STUFF
thinks wait you're a witch I'm not
[Music]
what's in here hi welcome to the Queen
sex dungeon aka the fun dungeon what the
that might be the worst thing I've ever
seen
the kingdom is super foot
princess I'm here to save you kill like
what are you obsessed with me
stalkers it's my job to polish you wet
turns into diamonds I know how to feel
dress a man and use him as a sleeping
bag skin that's cozy as hail thank you
[Music]
I am 39 I've had a couple bad dates I
went in something kind of different so
you seeing anyone just how's he doing at
home no pet he's an emotional support
dog you can tell when I get anxious
take a deep breath I used to be such a
Rach you're hysterical
he's not just a top he's a good boy and
he's made all your anxieties disappear
like magic this is my home
I met promise to protect it me and this
family can't break it this is survival
it's called economic evolution it's cute
I'll be killed
you're sealing yourself into the animal
this valley is mine come and get it I
plan to
Yellowstone's new season premieres
Father's Day Sunday June 21st I'm a
paramount Network mr. Mason
certain matters require discretion and
Phineas that's kind of thing you're good
at where your good suit this is my good
suit your detective mr. Mason
too fancy word for a busybody but yes
it's very easy for you to break the
rules isn't it and you never accept any
help come on I have a look you stay in
the truck how can we help you mr. Berg
early members of my church but
unspeakable act has visited upon them
kidnapping gone way wrong where's the
ever seen what do you mean I see we do
what we don't like when there's a
greater good to be served you more than
anyone should know that
the devil put Charlie Dotson in this box
mr. Mason it's hard to believe that
you're the right person for the job
I'm the only person to this job all
they've got is innuendo circumstance we
have to go after him why you getting so
hard the way I play the game you want to
know things
mr. Mason you want to prove things what
comfort is that ever given you
blessed be the pen who will gather
evidence against the devil you're saying
the police are involved in the cops the
church
[Music]
and just about out of moves
he said just about out of moves
so what's the move Vic I met a lot of
terrible mistakes my left and Shaggy
nobody really makes would you just say
Charlie makes he's on the TV
I'm the one who's supposed to kill it
you're tall said so bagging my tiles
said you find him I didn't finish the
job
wait wait mr. banks awake
[Music]
did the gasping and her load up the race
hello young lady
there's a cost of everything I'm just
trying to protect my son he knows where
we are Vic I'm gonna kill him one
superloft
[Music]
and dream these sheep need a shepherd
that is something that harmony and hope
will never be able to do the church is
gonna be torn down
[Music]
it's over when do you want to get
married it's important we don't drag our
past
- I let you be dragged into captivity by
this monster
we are family
do you think we counsel happy
[Music]
maybe there's a yeah a video online like
a barrier dead body on you too and I
think we want that in our search
histories search party season 3 coming
soon catch up on seasons 1 and 2 on
demand and on the TBS app classically
defraud bonfá descendants and run
furnaces ender vinicio
Allyson Liam for left in sook our teases
my pedestal edster to co-sign convey the
laughter ding fail these are Norton less
decision illusion in their money and
guns furnish that
dismissed him Dobis Alice Osteen when is
under Titus 2:14
you'd heard of Zodiac killer you heard
of Son of Sam the Golden State killer is
one of the most prolific violent serial
rapists and eventually a murderer and
the tragedy of this case to me is that
it's not better now Patton Oswalt
sitting here with the lovely and
intelligent
Michelle McNamara my wife and creator of
one of the best written and creepiest
crime blogs on the web I just obsessed
over it what drives me is a need to put
a face on a unknown killer
after my husband and daughter fell
asleep I hunted the killer with my
laptop
she was doing two things at once she was
writing both and she was trying to solve
a case she had material that other
investigators had never seen she
introduced you to the lives of the
victims and made you care I had a murder
had it and it was bad I would feed it
for the rest of my life although she
never had a badge and a gun Michelle
always was one of us he'll be silent
forever and I'll be gone in the dark he
threatened a victim
open the door show us your face
and walk into the light
you
[Music]
you